y ojén comenzamos con la decisión de
suspender la certificación al gasoducto
nord stream 2 una decisión polémica en
alemania como ha sido visto desde la
política y la sociedad alemana
bueno en realidad es importante destacar
que siempre ha sido un tema muy
controversial y que mucho del apoyo
deriva sobre todo por lado de algunos
políticos regionales deriva del uno
podría decir de la corrupción
estratégica por rusia pero también así
una gran parte de la población alemana
está consciente que alemania depende en
cierta medida de los flujos de gas por
rusia pero y eso me parece muy curioso
rusia
esencialmente ha dañado esa posición por
ya interrumpir los flujos de gas antes
de cualquier incidente con ucrania antes
de empezar también esa decisión de
reconocer esos territorios ucranianos
como independientes en ese sentido es un
proceso curioso todavía no está muy
claro qué pasó en rusia qué pasó con ese
interés
importante ya veremos cómo recibimos más
formación
muy bien y cómo podría afectar esta
decisión al precio de la energía en
alemania y en europa en general y cree
que puede ser una medida que acabe
afectando más alemania- agua rusia
en realidad no tenemos suficiente
información para juzgar eso
norm string 2 hubiera existido para
llevar más gas ruso a alemán
básicamente no necesariamente afectaría
la seguridad energético en la alemania
como está ahora aunque puede haber
obviamente contra sanciones por parte de
rusia
también los precios dependen de tantos
factores que es imposible decir cómo van
a ser los impactos inmediatos de esa
decisión y también los precios en
general de gas han sido elevados por la
demanda aumentada en asia y otros
factores
así que van a hacer cálculos
retrospectivos en algunas semanas de
todas formas rusia ahora sabe que
alemania se ha decidido en este caso de
estar con sus aliados en occidente y de
apoyar aunque todavía no cómo sería
como se había deseado pero si apoyar a
ucrania en esa disputa con producir
por tanto si rusia decidiera
contraatacar contra con su acciones
contra alemania o el precio de la
energía se hubiera usted cree que solos
podría verse presionado en alemania y
que quizás tuviera la oportunidad de
retroceder en esta acción o no sería
posible
hoy dijo en términos bastante
definitivos que él no apostaría en
volver al proyecto de north stream que
había sido una decisión bastante
decidida y obviamente que quiere evitar
la impresión que no se puede volver a
buenas relaciones nunca
pero mientras las cosas son así como
están entre rusia y ucrania no creo que
puedes retroceder con esta decisión
sobre todo porque básicamente el
invierno está atrás para alemania y en
los próximos meses rusia no puede
extorsionar comparar el flujo de gas
porque vamos a entrar a primavera y ya
no será tanto la necesidad